professional Apex Legends is falling
apart over the last 10 months some of
the game's biggest organizations have
decided to cease all operations and on
top of teams like liquid G2 C9 as of
last Friday NRG has become the latest
org to pack their bags and leave as a
result it's left many people wondering
who is to blame for this recent Mass
Exodus
so on Friday North American org NRG
announced their wholesale departure from
Apex Legends NRG has been a part of the
scene since pretty much the beginning so
the community was reasonably gutted by
this news at the same time Energy's
capped in sweet dreams released a video
of him explaining the situation and
although he seemed hopeful about his own
future he did have an opinion on why
this actually happened to many of you
this may come as a surprise but to the
team of people inside of energy this has
been a long time coming NRG began
scaling back their Apex interest when
they parted ways that the majority of
their content creators earlier this year
along with that energy also did not have
a merch booth at any of the lands and
seemingly was not very interested in the
esport unfortunately EA is mostly to
blame here considering the orgs and EA
never reached an agreement about a
revenue share and as much as a spec
seems like it's doing great during land
time there are some foundational issues
that limit the esport from growing any
further this did seem to be a mutual
decision between the actual team and the
org itself and sweet later did admit
that there were a lot of factors
involved but as he made it clear most of
his ire is directed towards EA and not
just for the woes of his own current
situation but the actual overall health
of the current Esports scene a sentiment
that's widely held by much of the Apex
Community you see EA has long been
criticized for not doing enough to
actually support the orgs example
providing them with opportunities to
actually make money something
desperately needed right now for a
multitude of reasons rosters are very
expensive from player salaries to daily
operations so much so that tournament
earnings and even sponsorships aren't
enough to keep things going for a lot of
teams because of this many orgs look to
the actual game companies themselves
since they're pretty much the only ones
capable of making meaningful amounts of
money off of the player base how you may
ask well it's simple
microtransactions if you look at
Counter-Strike for example teams who
qualify for Majors make a considerable
amount of money off of sticker sales
like a ton same goes with the Dota 2
battle pass and even rocket League team
decals orgs can sell as many dry fit
jerseys as they want but it will never
compare to the money you can make from
in-game Cosmetics but to get that you
are at the behest of the video game
companies luckily though this exact
thing was going to happen in Apex
Legends last year it was rumored that a
revenue sharing program was in the works
where select orgs would make money off
of Team skins however according to
multiple sources EA denied the 5050
Revenue split teams were asking for and
instead would only offer a one-time flat
licensing fee of sixty thousand dollars
counter negotiations went nowhere and
eventually EA scrapped the entire idea
completely ever since Orcs have been
dropping like flies and in this most
recent case people at NRG specifically
cited this failed Revenue split as a
reason for their exit all of this has
continued to add fuel to the fiery
debate online regarding who is
responsible for the current state of
Apex Legends EA for not playing ball or
the orgs for not doing enough to
diversify their revenue streams listen
on one hand yeah orgs probably shouldn't
have been so naive as to assume EA was
going to actually do something to
benefit anyone other than themselves and
sure they don't have the obligation to
either but at the same time it's not
ridiculous for these teams to need to
rely on EA in the first place Esports as
a whole is generally not doing too hot
right now and teams are running out of
ways to make money sure everyone on
Reddit may seem to have the answer as to
what these orgs are doing wrong but it's
not that easy if you sit down and try to
think of a new way for a team to make
money it's probably a been tried already
or B bad idea if valve stopped
their revenue splits tomorrow their
scenes would probably look a lot
different by the end of the year now I'm
not saying that orgs are completely
blameless in all of this but EA just
like valve and Riot are well aware of
the state of things and this could have
been an easy way to pump just a little
bit of life back into the scene and you
know in turn support the players who are
the ones that drive the fans to actually
buy these cosmetics in the first place
now nobody makes any money and the scene
loses the big orgs that help legitimize
it sure competitive Apex isn't dying
tomorrow but it does diminish some of
the Prestige once again just another day
in the life of the current Esports
industry fact is teams just cost more to
run than what orgs often want to pay it
sucks but it's the truth and
realistically game companies don't need
to lift a single finger people are still
going to play Apex Legends for fun and
buy the battle pass with or without NRG
do I personally think that a booming
Esports scene elevates a game in both
longevity and Legacy absolutely does EA
give a about my opinion no but
what do you guys think
well like the thing is is like like I
mentioned other games have the benefit
of having like these Revenue splits and
it may seem like trivial from the
outside but like you make so much money
like Navi said they made like over a
million dollars in sticker sales and
like it pays the players too it's it's
like crazy amounts of money and I'm not
kidding where like these big teams will
disappear if valve stopped doing that
because it just wouldn't be worth it for
them